hey youtubers is Charlie so
huge news everyone's freaking out Robert
Angier has just been cast in captain
america:
3 is gonna be a breakdown and what's
going on behind the scenes because
apparently it cause some big problems
behind the scenes at Marble
actually took a line ago she eating in
at one point he was cut out the movie
then put back in
so there's a lot of drama pollute any
new people if you just fighting for the
first time at the Marvel and DC videos
every week be sure to subscribe to get
everything
the first things first here's what we
know about the movie itself to be titled
the working on adapting
are civil war in onside obvious the Iron
Man Captain America 2
very important characters to those
stories on Sun is essentially the
follow-up to civil war
just explain things a little bit better
at to get into minor spoilers for the
comic so
if you want to you can just meet the
idea until this point attack goes away
everybody re okay year ago Civil War
split the Marvel Universe
over the idea of superhero registration
the government wants everyone to
register their secret identities
the kennedy this me expend movie
universe with the new registration at
the same idea
Captain America takes the people side
and says no
everyone does not need to give up their
identities and me and take them to the
government
remembers Stark Enterprises get a
shitload of money from the government so
obviously to start being the catalyst is
gonna side with the money
big battle goes down eventually Captain
America get assassinated
there's like a whole separate plot going
on with that it deals with the Reds goal
it's not super important for this story
right now mon-sun
the other story that they're thinking
about adapting for the movie is the
follow-up to civil war
just deals with the aftermath Captain
America's debt
obviously we all know Captain America
comes back to life in it involves
big-time trouble storyline
been is an interesting way for them to
invoke the time jam
and obviously that jan has to come into
the Marvel Universe at some point
that's with the story the movie is
supposed to be here's the story
what's going on with Robert Downey
junior in the movie originally it was
planned for him to have a brief cameo
but Robert Downey junior wanted a bigger
part the change the story but because he
ended up being a much bigger part in it
they had to pay a lot more money and the
Marvel executives like The Wanted sign
the checks
did not want to do that so they ordered
him to be
written out in the movie Kevin Fahey
president a Marvel Studios
are you to getting back in individually
Robert energy newspeople
can fight the in Marvel Studios came to
an agreement that agreement
amounts to about forty million dollars
and pay as a lot of money
yes the patent they're using to justify
that payday
is that by putting robert and you in the
movie it will boost the box office gross
immensely so they'll make their money
back or at least that's what they're
hoping
obviously before all this happens though
the jersey jumbotron has to go down
in the idea is that the fallout from
that movie will be were all this chaos
starts
alt run supposed to press the Avengers
so obviously is going to be destroying a
lot of people
effect he asked that will probably
create the red in the Avengers
supposedly Captain America is not
supposed to be in Avengers 3
if the vendors do have a falling out
after a Jumbotron
in captain america: three turns into
civil war that could explain why he's
not going to be
in Avengers 3 the funny thing is that by
putting robert downey junior
in captain america: essentially turns it
into a pseudo
Avengers take movie I mean he's too big
a character
for to just be about Chris Evans there's
also been a lotta rumors
did to cast inventors 3 won't involve
most in the main eventers it'll be like
an alternate roster
the civil war story line in the comics
leaves this big boy
in essentially a new team Avengers comes
in it's a whole separate plop it turns
into a dark rain and dark Avengers
essentially the normal Avengers are all
scattered off until the form Secret
Avengers
it's really complicated but physically
all the normal Avengers
are going to be Avengers anymore the
people that are writing Captain America
are also in talks to direct Avengers 3
so it makes sense that the captain
america: 3
civil war story line will direct the
crossover with Avengers 3
the conventions three will be the
follow-up to civil war
essentially would you have is you have
to dangers in a non Avengers movie
lotta money being thrown around lots a
drama behind the scenes I think it'll be
really interesting
the real question though is that how are
they going to deal with the civil war
story line in the comics
like how they can alter that a lot of
the characters like spider-man belong to
other franchises
spider-man to be character in civil war
I know there's been a lot of talks about
Sony including Eminem injures 3
that still possible but I'm not going to
make any Pieris about it until I see
something definite
to restart at its core though is a
character that all about control
controlling is environment with
technology so it's possible that will
use the
age in miracles so to speak are mutants
or whatever they want to call it inside
the Marvel Universe
as makeup in for superhero registration
so with all this mean for Chris Evans
Robert Downey junior
obviously Robert engineer has a separate
contract he's not unlike that six movie
contract that everyone else is on
Chris Evans only has one more movie
after Captain America three so
if he sits out Avengers 3 gotta give him
one more movie
you be able to retake the mantle in a
future movie Robert Angier is a whole
other story
in his own words he said he's going to
ride the superhero wave
into the shore that is means he's going
to be inside the Marvel Universe
as long as not keep making deals with
him he's the biggest expense right now
making deals with him as pie when the
hardest things for them to do and when
you make deals better that big
its we more complicated legally and
financially
if you ever wonder why Marvel just
doesn't announce everything at comic-con
is because
homes legal dramas going on behind the
scenes trying to work out deals with
people
it's been reported though that is
Captain America deal is finalized like
it's gonna happen
not gonna rewrite the movie again I do
like the pot today
rewritten it a couple times already like
he was in the movie
in a studio boss ordered an outside
their own out in the room back in
it's crazy the other really interesting
thing is if Chris Evans is gonna sit out
Avengers 3 does that mean someone else
is going to take the mantle Captain
America
right now I would seem a leading
candidate would be Anthony Mackie
that's basically what they did in the
comic stock and took on the mantle of
Captain America
right now just as we're getting lead or
like marbles shuffling allotted
characters ran the titles
you did not is that they would make
bulky Captain America it done both
things in the comics
both the Falcon in winter soldiers
separately
on separate occasions have been captain
america: let me know if you would rather
see though
would you rather see the Winter Soldier
take on the mantle Captain America
or would you rather see the Falcon
become captain america: missus for
Avengers the reasons the long ways off
because it's still really big deal not
by be reporting on this for the next
couple days
or do a follow-up to this story in my
agent to shield video tonight
so be sure to subscribe to get that and
if you have any questions I might do a
few cue any questions just because is
actually interesting to talk about
if you guys are interested in like the
business the Hollywood sign holders
superhero movies just let me know and
I'll include it in my future videos
I find it very fascinating but sometimes
people find it boring right now that pic
you for a breakdown in the Avengers 2
trailer from comic-con
in click here to learn about Captain
Marvel maybe being in the movie
thank you so much for watching lots of
high five and his eke out a little bit
the dot
arm and being in Captain America movie